for a British Junior doctor like Ashley
Macklin Doherty free time away from work
is rare and far from relaxing
she's a cancer specialist with a young
child at home and she's currently
struggling to pay her bills in Britain's
Capital also its most expensive city
when I'm waking up at two in the morning
worried about the patient I've just
given chemotherapy to
I want to also feel like I don't have to
also wake up worrying about the credit
card bills and the gas bills and the
energy you know the things that everyone
else is worrying about as well
yes thanks in part to these Financial
pressures she's joining tens of
thousands of other doctors in strike
action that starts today
[Music]
it's the second such strike this year
with the medical Union that represents
young doctors demanding a 35 pay rise
from the government after years of below
inflation wage increases
Macklin Doherty says due to the
government's spending choices UK
Healthcare is like a sinking ship if
you're in a system where the walls are
crumbling around you
um which I think is very much linked to
pay cuts you then get to a kind of
critical point where you have to
either stand up for what you what you
believe in
um
or you just accept and leave
such stress has driven thousands of
British doctors out of the profession or
into depression with some even
considering suicide according to Zaid
al-najar they struggle more than they
used to
mainly due to the lack of resources now
on the conditions under which they have
to work and that's been exacerbated by
the pandemic Al najas the medical
director of an organization that treats
doctors with mental health difficulties
and says many of their problems are
systemic given reduced resources and
staff shortages a lot of it is due to
excessive workload working conditions
worry about making errors worries about
causing harm worry about not being able
to provide what it is that you've felt
you could provide going into the
profession burnout rates in British
medicine were high before the pandemic
the pressure's now driving them even
higher
many doctors feel strike action is the
only remaining recourse to help the
public and politicians realize these
problems are real and require rapid
resolutions
Villa Marx Al Jazeera London